today by Stanley of religiosity
splitting with instead for incremental
changing optimization of new structures
so so this is some of the new ideas that
we came up for optimizing neonatal
structures using some ideas from
functional faint descent so it have been
talking a lot about the parameter
optimization but optimizing the
architecture or the structure of the
network is also in fact an even more
important problem independent right so
often you know from the in Pengo studies
we find that a dramatic improvement
sometimes can can be obtained by
discovering new types of neural networks
so optimizing new network structure is
also a key bottleneck for automatic
machine learning where we need to
automatically decide the structure of
the neural networks
forgive for the given data sets that we
have right and in addition for
energy-efficient settings were we are
interested in learning small compact in
your networks that have fast the
infinite time and energy consumptions
for applications such as mobile devices
Internet of Things in this case we want
to have small network around on the
things like mobile phones so that we
need a very low energy cost right in
this case architecture search algorithm
would be very important for balancing
accuracy and television cost
unfortunately architecture optimization
is a is a very difficult problem so it's
a discrete optimization file is a
comment or optimization when very large
search space very expensive evaluation
process right and mostly in the
literature even though we have developed
a huge literature architecture search
most of them are based on blackbox
optimization procedures such as an
evolutionary algorithm or policy
gradient reversal in error these
algorithms does not not really leverage
the fundamental mathematical property of
this problem the dissipation problem in
fact it appears that that's almost no
mathematical structure there that we can
exploit mathematically in order to
devise new algorithms so and this walker
is motivated by sort of de veau be some
mathematical motivated ideas for solving
architecture search in particular we are
going to develop something that is very
similar to gradient descent but for
structure optimization so so we will
leverage a very simple idea that in fact
we can view the Co optimization of the
parameters and structures as a function
optimization problem in the space of
disputes so it's a simple idea so I will
explain very quickly what it is and then
we will derive quite practical and
simple algorithm that in fact
incrementally grow a new network
iteratively by splitting your arms into
multiple copies so I also explain what
this means the India and this algorithm
is actually quite popular fast and
allows us to get compact and accurate
architectures for for many practical
results
so here's the key idea it's a very
simple idea so the problem is that we
can actually because the neurons are
exchangeable right so we can view the
optimization of the weights as
optimizing over the distribution of the
weights and because the distribution of
weights encodes both the number of
neurons and the parameters and if we
search through the distribution space we
are automatically optimizing the
structures right so most specifically
here is a simple problem or example
where we have a simple to layer new
network Sita I are the weights of the
neurons right
so typically we formulate this
optimization problem capital Phi is some
loss function and is the distribution of
the distribution distribution of the
data and then because the neurons are
per mutable I can actually equivalent
leap Ram tries the new net will be using
the dispersion of the neurons
so Rho represents the empirical measure
of the neurons right and then the
function now the new lithography is now
paralyzed by the distribution role
taking the expectation of the neurons
and then the optimization can be relaxed
into optimization over Rho the
distribution again you know because now
we are the distribution so if you change
the distribution in some smooth way you
can actually also change the the number
of neurons right and and in this way if
we search through the space of
dispersions we can actually search
through different types of architectures
right so this is the idea so if the Rho
is actually an empirical manager if we
can actually have a way to maintain Rho
to be an empirical matter of final
number of particles during our search
space then we'll get a practical
algorithm right so this idea can also
extended naturally to more general cases
when you have multiple types of neurons
or neurons in different layers in that
case we just have a joint optimization
of a bunch of weight distribution of
weights where
so here role I represents the the
distribution of the weights on the ice
layer right okay so we want to solve the
optimization
let's review what's happening for for
the parametric case most most of the
cases we use steepest descent for
optimizing parameters right we are going
to extend stupids descend before for the
function of space in your practical way
but let's have a very brief overview of
of the parametric case right so the idea
is that you know it's really at each
iteration we update a parameter set at t
from to see 30 plus 1 by by finding the
optimal the fastest descent point when Z
is a small neighborhood of the parameter
from the last iteration it seems like so
so so so here so here the loss is
indexed by both the parameter and the
architecture so doesn't need to join
that so give your architecture you do
need to chain to find the optimal Sita
but here the row is including both the
architecture and the parameter so you
don't need to change so it's a pram to
instructor Co optimization
Rowe is actually a doubter major yes a
bunch of other concepts so we all have a
way to make sure it's always a delta
function within the optimization so but
going back to the parametric case this
is standard right so if we do steepest
descent which means you want to find the
optimal points with the small
neighborhood of your solution then in
the now station points we have the
gradient descent gives you a first-order
improvement or v-strom and then at the
non station set of points
non non stationary point sorry at the
set of points or download the local
optimum local maximum then we have these
eigen descent where we follow the the
eigen minimum eigen direction of the
hessian matrix which gives us
second-order decisions now in practice
we've now already know that we can just
escape the saddle points using random
initialization or random noise winds are
calculating the eigen directions and
then the algorithm will converge on the
copy or local minimum so we want to do
fence that is parallel to this for the
functional case and the idea is simple
so here's a simple generalization we are
still doing steepest descent but now we
are doing it in the space of
distributions right and here we need to
actually define some notion of distance
the distance has to measure the
difference between two different
distributions so here the key is really
that we want to choose the distribution
the distance so that we can actually get
a practically imputable algorithm by
following this derivation what that
means is that I need to choose the
parametric properly so that if my roti
is an empirical measure of a finite
number of neurons right which
corresponds to a practical
funny sighs new network then following
in this derivation my roti plasma has to
always also be a finite size new network
and I also want to make sure that from
rotate to rotate as well the computation
is fast as fast as something like
gradient descent so I can actually
practically implement this others I
think I'm having a question related to
the previous question but to make
exactly more concrete so just for the
sake of example if you had a narrow
network with a single hidden layer yeah
and the only architectural modification
is the number so in that case what is
role exactly because all I'm thinking is
the number of neurons is the extra
parameters in the additional weights yes
and so what the distance what I use
between the distributions and so so I
will talk about that in the next slide
so we are just going to use the
washstand distance so in that case if
you have a let's see a one hidden layer
neural network during the weights are
really a bunch of points right even
though you cannot determine the number
of points but then for to set a point
you can calculate you can view them as
two distributions and calculate the
water safe distance so this is what I
mean okay so so we decide to use washes
their metrics for the properties that we
wish in the last two slides so basically
so here's the P Washington distance so
for giving two distributions flow and go
prime which could be just two sets of
points and then the the P washes and
distance is the minimum transport cost
measured by the LP norm right and then
we also have the infinite wash system
metric which is the case when P goes to
infinity so this is the case when
instead of using a P norm and taking
expectation of
over the coupling we actually just take
the soup over over the paths right so in
this case we are trying to find the
minimum where's the case these days for
both of these two cases we can sort of
visualize the structure of the
neighbourhood of these two cases for fan
IP for any given power beta mask let's
see this thought represents our neuron
for the epsilon neighborhood of P washes
then would allow you to arbitrarily move
the the pervading mass winds this when Z
indices own neighborhood so in this case
this family mass is split into three
locations with the smaller weights right
but because we are taking P norm here
and it's an expectation so we can also
actually move this probability a very
small portion of the probability mass
into somewhere there is very far
waveform from the original points right
and this is because the cost is measured
by the expectation right
but this non-local update is actually
something that we don't want because
when Z in the algorithm we only do local
search we don't want to do a global jump
that will require some higher
computational cost to solve an inner
loop a problem so in order to eliminate
that we actually decide to use use in
water stand magic so in this case any
given power a mass is allowed to
transport arbitrarily with Z in the
sleep symbol which is local update but
you can never go outside of the epsilon
ball this is some good candidate for our
algorithm sorry so Rho is assigned right
to this signed up for because of the WI
so how this sample is so so here we
actually assume let's say W is always
positive because you can always scale
them properly you will assume this also
later always the W is so so we just
assume that yeah but it doesn't you
prints the practical algorithm
okay so today if we just use infinite
washstand distance and we can follow the
formula that we had earlier to divide
the steepest descent that's a standard
procedure to do that it turns out if you
work out what color it we can find that
this is this infinite Washington stupid
descent is a combination with two types
of updates why is that it obviously
contains parametric steepest descent
what it means is that at a non station
points we are going to update the
parameters just by minimizing the
parametric loss without introducing
changes over the structures let's say
you have n particles originally we will
just keep the impart occurs and just
update each particle using gradient
descent so this is a standard gradient
descent without structural change and
then in addition to that so so in terms
of neighborhood this is a corresponding
to just moving the probability mass no
that's not related that's totally
different but that one also has a watch
dangers that's what watch you're sent to
discuss this is also this is also a
shallow Network no this can be extended
to higher to to more general deep neural
networks I can comment on the difference
between two washes Stan versus even
washes
it won't be a multi-layer one I will
explain later yeah so I promise you it
will be obvious to extend this okay so
so so it includes two parts one is the
steepest descent another is leading
so splitting means that in addition to
just moving the particles we can
actually also split the particles
because this is this is not allowed in
original Euclidean space but it is
allowed it in the functional space
because now we are winning these neurons
there's particles right so so most
specifically let's say we let's say we
have a theta which is the neural and
have a weight magnitude W we can
actually speed the neuron into a
combination a bunch of theta theta I and
W I such that the sum of the weights
equal to W right and then we can also so
so the city I would be different from
from theta so we in this case we are
actually augmenting the structure of the
neural network so it turns out I will
show the derivation later it turns out
these types of update only gives you a
second-order
improvement meaning that this kind of
update only happens at the stationary
point so at mass station point you are
going to just do a typical gradient
descent at the station point then you
actually has the option of performing a
splitting right and then it is that
what's happening is that this kind of
operation this bleeding allows us to
escaping saddle points in the Washington
space but local Optima in the Euclidean
space let's say you run a standard
gradient descent and it converged and
that means just by updating the
parameters that's no way to improve the
algorithm right and in this case we can
actually introduce bleeding which means
we are going to introduce new neurons
and that in the in this higher
dimensional space that's actually
dementia it's possible that there are
directions that allows us to further
decrease the loss
but what is the cost of increasing the
size of the neural network so he's a
internal new network he is what's
happening let's see you have a neuron
and then what we can do the operation we
are introducing is to copy this new one
into two copies and then each of them we
save a small a portion of the weight and
then we can update the parameters of
these two neurons
jointly so here's a part that I want to
I think it is very intuitive so
basically what's happening is if you are
rounding a standard gradient descent
without changing the structure at some
point you will get reach a local optimum
that means you can no longer update your
you can no longer improve your loss by
just updating the particles right so so
it's think about each of neuron is is a
ball like this right so there are
actually two cases in the station point
why is in this case where you are pre
pulling the ball in to the opposite
direction so in this case see if you
actually speed the ball the ball will
actually separate and the energy will
decrease right so this is the splitting
unstable case this is the case we can
actually improve the neural network
improve their accuracy by splitting the
neural network the nuance and this is
the case of speeding stable which means
that even if you speed a ball from the
middle because the the forces are pushed
together the updates well there won't be
no update even if you push them away a
little bit there will be push the back
right so the question is can we actually
identify these two cases right and then
in the case of unstable the instability
case how can we actually divide the
optimal update strategy so I guess so
supposing the a standard prioritization
you split suppose you are at a local
minimum but it is local minimum in the
parametric space so no no so it is a so
so let's see if you
right before splitting you have a one
dimensional Euclidean space in that
space you're you are reaching a local
minimum but after you split you get two
dimensions so in the two dimensional
space it could be a saddle point because
the additional dimension could be either
stable or unstable okay so that you can
even have any parallel if you increase
the primer space
okay
okay so I think here might be a easier
way to understand all this place wins
out of functional analysis so here I'm
good actually going to do a very simple
case just you know a single neural
network well I
we just have a single neuron sigma theta
X right
in this case the loss is a very simple
function like this and then assume we
actually speed this neuron into M copies
sin-hye and then each of them has a
weight WI right and then in this case we
get a Augmented loss the loss is going
to be a function of both data and W and
then it's by replacing sigma theta x
when's the weighted sum of the of the
copies right obviously if you take theta
equal to theta and WI put the sum of W
are equal to 1 then then the Augmented
loss equal to the original loss right
meaning that even if you split you keep
the weights to be the same you get the
same Network right so now you want to
derive the steepest descent what we need
to do is to actually optimize this
automatic function so we need to choose
the optimal number of copies M right as
well as the values of each copy and the
weights such that the loss is minimized
our mental loss is minimized so here we
have this constraint that for every copy
theta I minus theta has to be smaller
than Epsilon
this is because the infant washes then
never hurt right and then sum of weights
equal to 1
and Prussian bucks
okay so it's a very simple optimization
formulation and then it's actually a
simple problem so in order to divide the
solution is convenient to decompose the
difference between city I I do SATA in
to the sum of Delta average which is the
average displacement of all the copies
as well as Delta I which is the
individual splitting direction so such
that the weighted sum of the Delta I
equal to zero like so so what means is
that if Delta average equal to zero
I'm not updating the overall average of
the particles I'm just splitting them
into opposite directions well but if you
have the data averaged so the overall
average is also updated and then where
is this we can have this simple Taylor
expansion for the Augmented loss a
pencil dollar main loss equal to a sum
of two terms the first term is the
effect of the average displacement what
this means is that it's equivalent to
just updating the parameter without
splitting just keep the original neuron
and just update it by Delta average
right so this is going to be a standard
gradient descent and then the second
term is the effect of splitting so what
what this term is it's this term is
actually a weighted sum of quadratic
term which depends on Delta I which is
the individual splitting direction as
well as as theta as theta is is some
matrix that I call spreading matrix
defining in this way it is a semi
Hessian matrix because the by definition
it's going to take the first duty of Phi
which is the loss and then take the
second derivative for the neural network
right so this will be a D by D matrix
what is the dimension of the factors of
the of the norm
so and then following this because we
are decoupling the displacement and
splitting we can try to find the optimal
reading strategy by minimizing the
second splitting term right now because
it's a quadratic term it's very easy to
say that the optimal splittings strategy
is actually just splitting each of the
neuron
if the if the minimum eigen value of s
is smaller than zero right then we can
actually the optimal solution would be
just two splitting each other into two
copies with equal weights and the update
direction of each neuron is going to be
just follow the eigen direction of the
minimum eigen value for s theta right so
in this case it has this simple
structure so that it's both sufficient
and optimal to speed the neuron into two
copies or as equal weights and then if
the minimum eigen value is larger than
zero then no splitting can decrease the
loss in this case it's a split in stable
meaning that no matter how you split the
neurons it's going to be stayed the same
even if you split its own way it will be
pushed back so this is different right
so I'm saying the setting is different
one is when you have a parametric
optimization you are not increasing the
parameter you just split you just
decreased by eigen direction but here we
are actually increasing the parameters
so two sides away I guess I have an
answer for your question
okay so here we have this so here's just
another comment about the splitting
matrix so it's a it's a very has a very
interesting structure that has the mix
of first order do - and second order
duty
it's very similar to Hessian matrix
except that the Hessian matrix has an
additional term like bite really has a
state s theta which is the first term
and the second term is actually taking
the second tier 2 4 5 and then first
additive for Sigma right now one even
important comment is that s is actually
a easy part of the Hanshin I will show
why this is the case meaning that it's
actually much easier to calculate s than
T
yeah yeah he is the missing part of the
detention right so and the reason T is
more complicated is because let's see if
you have a huge inner network were sake
Sigma is only one than you are then
capital Phi is going to be highly
complicated you want to you don't want
to take a beauty for Phi and it's easier
to just take a duty for Sigma which is a
simple neural okay so and then now we
can actually characterize stability in
the wall system space so being stable at
Washington in space means that no matter
you how you update your parameter and no
matter how you split your parameters
once the update is in the local region
you can you are stable you can never
decrease the decrease the loss right so
from here we can show that the
Washington stability actually goes to
the standard parametric stability which
is which is the which is which is the
fact that you can never update your
Panter to increase the loss right even
by skipping the set of points right and
then the second part is this splitting
stability which means that even if you
are allowed to split into a minion or
servants or any number of neurons you
can never improve the performance so
it's a stronger notion of look happy
then you know so these two notions are
really orthogonal in general that's no
general relation that imply one or
another but if Phi is capital Phi is
actually comebacks which is the case of
one hidden layer neural network then the
splitting actually splitting stability
of a tree implies the implies the
primary stability meaning that if you
cannot split then you can also not
improve by just escaping satellite the
parametric stationary point is actually
optimal
so I guess we're playing with some of
these kind of ideas you know they have a
different context so I found that this
ice matrix is almost never
PSD like oh thank you ESS basically you
can always flex it subject is that what
you find it is it is it is sometimes but
I do find the cases you cannot split and
it's not open it's not a global optimum
and this is speaking so because this is
the the sake of us in the definition the
icing of the model
there's always now comebacks right you
mean this one on marks may or may not
because let's see if you usually you're
using Valu value is convex but your
weights could be either positive or
negative so it's unclear whether you
both be collects right so and because
this part this derivative part can also
be positive or negative so the
combination really the combination t
besides the overall positivity so it's
unclear how how to decide it
theoretically I also studied this and
try to figure out if there's a relation
but it's
you know that is what what is fine in
today's to expression okay
can you remind us what what by okay yeah
why is the loss function so so I'm just
assuming let's see the lotto bow or loss
function equal to the neural network
pushed into a function Phi so it could
be the quadratic function in the case of
min square regression or logistic loss
so it's argument is that is a
real-valued prediction yeah what is Phi
of T comma X made I think there was one
of those issue in the slide that we
write I would supply so I'm not going to
cover it v prime oh sorry it's a paper
it's a paper yeah yeah it's a typo you
should be this way again for a scene
yeah single vote yeah
okay so now this is the case for the
general deeper new network it pens out
exactly the same relation holds right
let's see you have n different title
mignons
or n different layers so the prompt so
say theta superscript and represents the
ends not right or ends population of
neurons because each neuron can have
multiple copies and then for each of
this know we can split it let's say just
split into multiple copies when it's
different weights then the overall
augmented loss is going to again equal
to the the loss you will get by just up
taking along the average direction
without changing the structure and then
you have this leading term which is
really just the sum of the splitting
matrices of the individual neurons right
so it's a very good result basically
shows that that's no crossing term in
the speeding matrix so this is another
reason I'm saying this video matrix is
the easy part of the Hessian matrix
because there's no cost in from and this
is the key because now you can calculate
all these things quite efficiently and
you can also just directly compare
different the splitting matrices of
different neurons right let's see I have
three layers or then for each of layer
then the for the neural of the each
layer I calculate the individual make 3d
matrix I can calculate the individual
eigen direction I can manuals and I can
compare them directly this allows us to
jointly decide the number of layer
normal neurons in each layer
so this is the overall algorithm yeah so
that was exactly wondering how the
objective is used to decide the number
of you know so how do you decide ml
number oh yeah it's always two it's
always two because because by by this
derivation if you want to optimize this
weighted average of these quadratic
things the optimal bleeding is always
just leading into two copies and then
each of the cop each of the copy follows
either the eigen direction order or the
opposite of the eigen direction so
there's no need to actually split into
multiple copies
so this is the overall algorithm so what
we are going to do is at each iteration
we just one standard gradient descent
until a local optimum is reached because
the if I'm at a saddle point I can
always just update a parameter to
improve the performance there's no
motivation to speak right so I will just
round either stochastic with InDesign or
any other algorithm until a local
parametric location is reached and then
I calculus pretty matrices for all the
neurons that can be splitted and then I
will just pick the neurons wins the most
negative eigenvalues minima eigen values
and let's breed these neurons following
the sprinting all these neurons into two
copies with eco weights and therefore
following the eigen directions
activation because you have one there so
let's say you have a yeah let's say you
have a new let's say you just have one
URL right so then for this particular
neuron you can calculate that splitting
matrix right which is a T by T matrix
where T is the number of parameter of
Daniel and then you calculate the eigen
vector of minimum eigen value for that
matrix and then you create two copies of
the neuron Y is plus the eigen direction
Y is minus the eigen direction for space
in the parameter space so let's see you
have some
[Music]
so let's say you have some parameter
theta I theta is going to be the weights
of the neural network right and then you
calculate this splitting matrix using
the formula I showed on the slide this
is going to be a deep IP matrix so so
the weight is RP then you calculate the
minimum eigen direction of this matrix
which is going to be which is going to
be a RT factor but and then what you do
when you split you speed this theta into
two copies why is the SATA plus some if
some step size we mean another is theta
minus if so each of them has a half of
the weight this is this strategy is
actually optimal following that of the
derivation
it's busy can you locate them wrong I
mean women is distributed over each in
your has away me so what do you have
pain your arms in the single arbitrary
let's say you have known otherwise one
minion or not neurons just for each of
the neuron you calculating you will get
1 million in a we mean right and then
you just split for this neuron there has
negative eigen vectors eigen values
and the dimension of this matrix depends
on the fan-in yep so it could be large
but it's much less than this overall
size
I'm just saying finding an eigenvector
just that popular I will adjust that
problem you know these ideas are doing
like Frank wolf the second order
approximation no no actually so it
that's where yeah so it's very related
it turns out Franco is is is doing
steepest descent when's when's well
should stand zero distance which is
equivalent to T cubed East elevation
distance but we are doing in Washington
different distance and the reason we are
doing this is because it only gives you
local update if you are doing washes
then if you are doing Franco off you
need to do the global update each an
innovation you need to add a new owner
by solving a global optimization and
this is exactly because for finite P
washes then you have this non-local
update
how much reduction in the loss it is a
gain and how does it depend on epsilon
so the reduction is going to be epsilon
square and how do you know when to sort
it has to be in peril
let's see nom de mie is smaller than
some special
left up the residual term
which is
it's going to be scaled by I mean this
is destined that's the Hessian of the
the value and then steps long skirts the
step size which you have another yeah
you're dropping yeah so you expense
you're dropping one of the terms system
next fine
aren't you dropping like this some this
is an eventual algorithm because it's
yes yes so it's the same right so
basically I'm saying that the optimum of
this term equal to this minus this so
this is the this is the improvement of
the loss by doing splitting
okay so so this is a simple
visualization of our algorithm let's see
this case we are actually using a mobile
mobile net or 710 starting from a small
network and each variation we run
through all the layers and calculator
eigenvectors and then decide which
neurons i should split like by splitting
yours in different layers we will end up
with architecture that is very different
from the earlier one accuracy increases
this green curve is what you do if you
increase the size uniformly this dash
line is the full size case and it's
actually reached much earlier than the
uniform uniform speed so I know the
eigen calculation is a big problem so we
have a efficient approximation for
solving it without actually expanding
the speeding matrix so the idea is
really just minimizing the Rayleigh
quotient so well we define this ratio
and then we find the optimal bead to
minimize that the minimum value is going
to be the minimum eigen value and the
solution is going to be the minimum
eigen direction and then we can do
brilliant descent or any other numerical
algorithm during this process we need to
evaluate this matrix vector product
which is speedy matrix times some
arbitrary vector V it turns out this can
be object how can quite conveniently by
using an auto auto differentiation trick
the idea is that you can check that this
F function which is constructed by
adding actual term on the output of each
neuron so this can be done in tensor
flow or anything else you just compile
this new neural network and then if you
take the gradient for this function at y
equal to 0 you will get this this
product right so and what's nice is that
if you have a blood in your network you
can actually add this term into the
output of each individual neuron and
then you will get overall function if
you just take a gradient for that
overall function you calculate this
product simultaneously for all the
neurons but and the computational cost
is almost the same as doing that
publication of the origin or network so
if you perform this overall process you
will get an algorithm that practically
rounds almost the same computational
cost as performing your standard
gradient descent ok so now we have some
empirical results so here's a simple toy
example x-axis is the number of
iteration of the gradient descent so
here we are splitting starting from one
single neuron you shall see that this
cliff points is when we are splitting
the neurons and you sort of see that it
really looks like escaping a set of
point and then that's a bunch of
baselines so here's a visualization of
this breeding process so here we are
training a in chaplain known at home
recently proposed by in which case so
this neural network has a special
interruptible layer in which case the
weights of the each neuron is enforced
to be similar to real estate there are
cells you can visualize the neurons so
here we start from one single neuron and
then I can sort of you can say it's
blurry likes nothing and then it split
into two neurons that is less Rarick and
then at this point you need to decide
which neuron to split it turns out this
points slatted so it is split into two
neurons that is similar but less blurry
and more in Chapel in the end this one
is evolved using gradient descent to ps3
and then this one is further split into
something that is like six and nine and
then two-ingredient descent and then
next up we decide to speed zero which
evolves to some 7 and 0 and then this
process evolves aren't you at
we have been good
so this is looking at a particular step
in this case we have three neurons and
then what we did is we copy the ID
interaction eigenvalue for each of the
neurons so we have five of them right
and this big pi is the eigenvalue and
this green thing is the actual loss if
we end up splitting each of the neuron
right we can so see that eigen direction
item value and the loss is correlating
well for this two direction to top I
top-ranked the neurons we can sort of
see that they are actually splitting
into something that is different meaning
that you are carrying input significant
gain versus for this one if you split
that you will get the same thing means
that there's no improvement so it is
doing something that is very reasonable
so here we have a comparison when
pruning methods you know self attended a
set so the idea is that our method is
grow in the new network starting from a
small network and gradually increase the
size right there has been a bunch of
algorithm that trying to do the opposite
in which case you change a large neural
network and gradually prom the
unimportant Your Honor these two curves
represents two of the recent toning
based methods and it's interesting to
say that our splitting method is
actually can be better than this be
toning methods even though the pruning
method is actually leveraging of the the
full size model which has more knowledge
and slower and then finally we have this
example on their keywords body so this
is when in vs. we did not expressly
compare you would be great to compare
but I don't think idea very different
here's the pruning you need to actually
start from your food
and then this is an example of keywords
body in this case so basically every
time we'll use Google assistant or for
any other intelligent assistant you need
to wake up the system by seeing some
words like okay Google or Google and
this is a d-pad bit back here or
spotting algorithms right this kind of
algorithm need to be divided on in
deployed it on the edge of devices and
has to be on all the time in order to be
being wake up and in time right so this
is obviously very energy consuming so a
Challenger has been developing small
size in your network that can still did
have these keywords with high accuracy
so here we use a recent benchmark by
John and oh and we can say that our
method can be better both in terms of
accuracy number of counters and number
of flops thank you very much your
architecture so it's always related oh
no it could be all kinds of
architectures anything in case of
searing we actually speed in the
channels just channels yeah did you find
that it needs to control the number of
please yeah we do need to control
basically we some we use heuristics like
every time speed some amounts so that we
don't get let grow up
how sensitive is the final architecture
when is respect to the initialisation I
don't really know I I think I we should
study that because often we just do one
because for this kind of deep learning
experiments is very expensive so we
basically just take a standard benchmark
and this shrink its size proportionally
and then just grow so I don't know how
to make a kind of reasonable starting
point but that's a very good question
it's actually not uniform it's it's just
it's a mobile net shrinked
proportionally so it's not exactly
uniform it's a very good question
I I don't know it splitting layers there
won't be a fundamentally different
question
so here spin neurons is a second-order
thing so you only need to split at the
stationary point and this is very nice
because you can rank within descent and
they split but if you speak in your
layers it turns out it's actually a
first-order thing meaning that if you
derive a functional algorithm a gradient
descent algorithm you know always split
so I don't know how to make it practical
yet it's a very good direction
yes yes this one so so each of the image
represent the weight of each in your
yeah so this is an one neuron and if you
s pleaded and one green empty sent on to
a convert this is the value on the other
tuned yours so and this is chocolate is
actually a special structure if you just
one fully connected you wouldn't get
such in yeah we actually post we
actually did both so it turns out
training from scratch actually improve a
little bit we don't know why no because
it's that's not allowed in a functional
gradient so even though you can do it
practically but it's not a part of this
out
and enjoy because rotovac deconvolution
Network kind of problems deconvolution
yeah we're actually trying something
like that we haven't got that fire
it's it very interesting
[Applause]